[Music]
foreign
this Fresh So if you wanted to follow
along you can do this as well
so
again I'm on bitbucket under the
bootstrapping microservices organization
under example two you come to the main
page here and you can click clone
that'll allow you to copy the command
you need to clone this so that's a git
command it's going to clone this locally
obviously I've already got a copy of
example two in fact I've got a two
copies of example two locally so I'm
going to make a third one and I'll just
call it working okay
so I'm going to clone that locally this
shouldn't take too long and it's done
that's awesome
so go down into working I'm going to
open Visual Studio code on this
directory so what we've got here
basically open in Visual Studio code is
a a fairly basic fairly typical node.js
micro service
again this could be any code this could
be Java it could be python so please
just pretend that I'm working with your
favorite programming language because
this is about and a Docker and terraform
it's not about you know which
programming language you use to do micro
services
um we got the the basic uh node.js stuff
you need here like package.json which
contains the dependencies
um and metadata about the project we've
got two Docker files we're going to look
at those in a moment um a Dev version
and a prod version I'll explain why we
need to in a moment
um you know if you're just getting
started you can get away probably with
just one Docker file but I have
different needs for development and
different needs for production and
that's why I have two separate ones
we've got a configuration file here
that's a yaml file it's a configuration
file for bitbucket pipeline so that's
where we can figure a continuous
delivery pipeline under Source we have
the source code for the micro service
it's just a simple uh let's have a quick
look at that that's what we're looking
at before basically where we changed uh
hello world to Hello computer which
you'll see just here
um so it's just a small simple really
trivial micro service implemented in
node using JavaScript
under the scripts directory here we have
various terraform files and a couple of
shell scripts to help us as well so
we're going to come back and we're going
to have a look at the code that's in
those in a moment but first I'm going to
show you how we build this
so I've got a Docker desktop for windows
installed but it's actually using the
wsl2
Linux uh what do you call it like sort
of
um back end for Windows like it allows
you to get
um basically any kind of Linux flavor
really running directly under Windows
um
so Docker uses that so so it's not it's
not I'm not running
um Windows containers I'm actually
running Linux containers but in a in a
Ubuntu wsl2 VM under Windows
um if you like working in Windows it's a
great way to work uh it might sound
complicated but I can you can trust me
it's fairly easy to set up uh I don't
have I've deleted all my local images so
when I do Docker image LS normally I'd
have a big list of images here that I
had cased locally or that I've been
building locally you know before this
session I've deleted all those just so
we can keep it simple and you can see
what I'm doing
and now I want to do the docker build
command I'm going to tag it
I just have to I've
just off to the side here I've got a
cheat sheet where I've got all important
URLs and stuff like that
so I'm just gonna have a look in here
and see if I can find my the address of
my
uh my Docker registry now there we go
so I'm just tagging this with the um the
registry that I want to push to
and uh what else do I need here I need
to give it a name so the Pod that I
already had running which is the same
part as I'm about to deploy and I don't
I don't want them to conflict
so I'm calling this pod instead of video
streaming I'm just going to call the
video I should really call it video Dev
or something but it doesn't matter you
know this isn't production this is just
um
simple example that I'm going to delete
after this session anyway
and now I need to
tell it which file to use so normally
you don't have to do this it will just
default to a Docker file but
I want to tell it to use my Docker file
prom
so I'm using the prod version of the
docker file
and tell it this this dot at the end it
tells it to work with the current
directory
so this is going to take a moment
because what it's doing now is it's
pulling down my base image I'm I should
really update this to a later version of
node but I'm using node.js 10. I'm using
the Alpine version of that so Alpine
Linux is a cut down version of Linux
which is smaller for production so
really good to if you want to reduce the
size of your Docker images that you're
um You're Building
so you can see here that it's uh oh it
went pretty quickly there but it
installed production dependencies we're
gonna have a look in the docker file in
a moment and see how this all works it's
copied source code in and we're we're
hard coding some videos you see here
it's copying the videos we're hard
coding them into our Docker image now if
you're making the next Netflix obviously
you don't want to hard code videos into
an image like this they're going to be
stored in some database somewhere but
you know just for this simple example
we're we're basically baking one video
into our uh our Docker image and we're
gonna that's the video that we're
playing when you hit the video route on
the web page you see here the command
for actually starting the microservice
npm star that's the conventional command
basically for starting a node.js
application if I do a Docker image LS
now you can see that I've got the node
base image that's the version 10 of node
and I've got uh this specially tagged
image here you've got the um unique ID
for the image here which you can use to
kind of do things with that as well
now I want to publish this image
somewhere where I can get to it in the
cloud so I can deploy it from my
kubernetes cluster the first thing I've
got to do though is I've got to log into
my Docker registry
so I'm going to use the docker login
command again I've got to just find my
the URL for my
registry
now if you're thinking this is a bit of
a pain I'm having to type all this stuff
into the command line yep that's why we
automate this and I'll show you how this
is automated after just after I've
showed you the manual process
so now I type in my username which is
icdemo and I'm just going to give my
password away to everyone no no one's
going to abuse this either hopefully not
um it doesn't matter anyway I'm going to
wipe out all this um after this after
this demo is complete this will all be
gone
so I'm just logging into my container
registry
and now I'm going to use the docker push
command to push my local version of this
image
up to my registry
and we called it version one this is
version one of this new uh new container
actually I might have to
this isn't going to work I think I've
actually already got a version one up
there right so I'm just gonna I'm just
gonna retarget
we'll rebuild it with a new tag let's
say let's say we're working with version
10 we've jumped ahead in time we're
working with version 10. uh I'm gonna
now
I'll do my Docker push now
version 10.
so this is now being pushed up to my
private container registry that I've got
running on on azure
you can obviously you can run container
Registries anywhere you could run it on
your own machine if you want
um you know you can run it on any Cloud
vendor it's um I've actually been
playing with um building these things
manually recently and there's a on
Docker Hub if you search for registry
you'll find the official image for the
docker registry that's that's by Docker
themselves so you can you can set this
up from scratch pretty easily if you
want to but there's a whole lot you've
got to consider obviously with security
um if that's the case before we get to
terraform let's have a look at um the
docker files that we just used so this
is the prod Docker file the first line
here shows you the image that this is
based on so it's based on node.js 10
using Alpine Linux to cut down the image
size
uh then we set a working directory to
work within for the build process within
the uh the docker image we're copying
across the package file and the package
log file that's what we need to install
dependencies
and then we're installing dependencies
so this is installing uh using npm the
node package manager to install
dependencies and this bit here only
production is basically saying we only
want the production dependencies we
don't want any of the development
dependencies so that you know cuts down
what we're going to install having a
more minimal footprint for our images
for production is good
then we're copying across all the
JavaScript source code I mean there's
only one file there's only one
Javascript file there but if you had
more that would also be copied across
then we're copying across the videos If
we have a quick look over here in the
videos directory you can see that's
where my sample video is an mp4 it's
just a really small video so just for
just good for testing
and then the command here is is
basically what we run to start
to start this application within the
container and we can see where this
start script is implemented if we go to
package.json so we're just looking at
package.json now you can see that
there's a start command here so when we
run npm start it actually runs this
little little snippet of command here so
it's saying to run node with the main
source file for this micro service
now there's also uh start Dev so that's
where I use nodemon it's similar to the
previous command except we're using node
mod instead of node
and what that's doing is it's going to
restart the micro service whenever the
code changes that's really important
that's that's live reload it's like hot
reload for within your container
so
when I when I when I started development
version of this which I don't talk about
I'm not gonna I don't have time to talk
about that really today you can find out
how to do that in my book bootstrapping
microservices but I when I when I run a
complete microservices application on my
local computer
I mean I'm doing that using Docker
compose and I'm and I've got it set up
for live reload across the entire
application so for each micro service
I'm using node mon
and then the difference with the dab
Docker file is that we don't copy the
code across nowhere here do you see the
code being copied across and in fact we
don't even bake the dependencies into
the image so what we're doing here in in
the start command for the for the
container
we're setting up the node.js cache or
the npm cache for caching dependencies
and we're doing the install at startup
time
and the reason for that is because the
the way this is working we'll be able to
kind of using shared volumes we'll be
able to Cache the end sorry share the
npm cache with the host operating system
so we're persisting the cache so every
time we build it build a new image and
we start a new container of it we're
going to reuse the same downloaded
dependency so that makes startup of a
container a lot quicker
and it makes building the container a
lot quicker as well because installing
dependencies in an image in while you're
building it is one of the slowest parts
of this
and then of course we run uh the
application the micro service with this
start Dev command so that's what enables
um node mon now the thing we're missing
here that I'm not showing today is the
docker compose file that sets up the
sharing of the volumes so that's in my
book though so if you're interested in
how to get a real efficient development
process working live reload for your
whole microservices application please
uh have a look at my book you can read
the first chapter three if if you go to
the web page I'll show you that at the
end of this so that's the docker file
that we just built sorry the prod the
prod version we'll go back to that this
is the docker file that we just built we
built an image from that uh we looked at
it using Docker image LS let's see that
again
so that shows your local images now you
can see we've got the previous version
one that I tagged and also the version
10 but I think I'd already kind of
published version one in my in my test
earlier so I just I didn't wanna cause
any problems
um
uh I basically overriding that
and then we then we push this image we
we pushed the version 10 of our image up
to our Docker registry
um so it's there a Docker image is there
it's waiting to be deployed to
kubernetes we just gotta we're just
going to use terraform to do that now
obviously you know you could use uh Cube
control you know something like create
deployment uh Dash Dash image and then
you type in the name you registry the
name your image and any other commands
any other options you want to apply to
that so we can use Cube control directly
to manually create this I'm not doing
that um I'm using terraform to do it the
reason I use terraform to do it is
because then it's like
it you know instead of just being you
know like a shell script with you know
running Cube control in in a continuous
delivery pipeline we've got a proper
language there for configuration
um and it's really smart terraform is
really smart as well kind of it knows it
knows the current state of your system
and it knows uh the changes that you
want to make to get it there and Cube
control just isn't that smart even
though we're using Cube control under
the hood we're using terraform but under
the hood we'll be using Cube control
um so let's have a look uh where we are
with the terraform code
close these files
so just under the um
scripts directory of this repo here all
the terraform files and then just some
helper shell scripts that I'll show you
in a minute that help us kind of put all
this together
um this this whole thing is designed to
run on a continuous delivery pipeline
um so it's got some back ends set up
here which which is what configures the
um the state the storage
um
like the back-end storage for the state
of the continuous delivery pipeline
um I don't need this running locally in
fact it's going to cause problems
because it might confuse my it might use
that persistent state of my live
continuous delivery platform as my local
state and I want that I just wanted to
have completely local state so I'm
commenting out the code that's in
backend.tf here
now to use terraform I've got to be in
the same directory as the terraform
script so I'm going to CD down to the
scripts directory we have a look there
that's where all our terraform scripts
are and the shell scripts as well
um I'm just going to check what version
of terraform I'm using because the thing
is I'm using um for this demo I'm using
an old version of terraform I'm using
version.0.12 but for my production work
at the moment I'm using 0.14 but I
haven't upgraded my demos to that yet so
I'm just going to stick for this demo
I'm just sticking with version 0 to 12.
and uh whenever you uh clone a fresh
terraform project and you want to run it
locally you've got to run terraformer
knit
if I can spell it right there we
go that's better so this is downloading
all the plugin providers that that I
need to use like the kubernetes provider
um
don't know if I need
there's your no so um
the reason that terraform can work with
any different type of cloud provider and
also work with kubernetes is because
it's all driven by plugins so there's
plugins for any kind of thing you want
to connect to and any kind of thing you
want to configure
um at least at least on the main ones
anyway so we have initialized now um
what that what that means is that we'll
have
hello uh let's do an LS minus l so you
can see everything oh you can't see the
hidden files it's all right um
but if we do an LS in the terraform
directory
so it it creates a hidden directory
called dot uh dot terraform and in there
is where it downloads all the stuff that
it needs
now
um now if I run terraform apply
it's going to automatically
um
but let's just show it so it's gonna
it's gonna look at all the TF files here
and it's going to execute the code in
these terraform files right but I've got
some inputs I've got some variables I
need to provide it like this one here I
need to tell it uh where to find my
Docker registry now I could enter that
all here like um let me show you
I'm just going I'm just copying and
pasting my registry name in That's all
good but the problem is when I get to
this point where it asks for the the
certificates like the the the keys that
I need to authenticate with my
kubernetes cluster if I try to copy them
to the command line something something
goes wrong it like it corrupts the key
or something like that it doesn't seem
to work so I'm going to create a little
batch file to do this now again I'm only
demonstrating how to do this manual
manually so we're gonna the ultimate aim
is to do this all automatically and so
you won't be sitting here typing stuff
at the command line you won't have to be
creating these kind of batch files and
stuff like that
um but let's just go back to code Visual
Studio code here I'm just going to
create a new file called um uh deploy
local dot bat this is a batch file
because I'm I'm just running it directly
under Windows here so I can't I can't
run a shell script unless I open a
Ubuntu
terminal so I do have Ubuntu running as
a virtual machine on Windows 10 but
I'm just going to keep things simple so
we want to run terraform apply
I'm going to set it up to Auto approve
otherwise you know you have to type yes
and that's that takes a lot of time
doesn't it so we want to speed this up
so we're going to Auto approve the
changes we're going to make I'm just
using the line continuation character
here so we're spreading one command out
over multiple lines now I'm passing in
variables directly so this is sort of
how we get this running on continuous
delivery as well is that we've got to
wire in all the variables that we want
to pass in so the first one in fact let
me look at my variables file
so this variable this TF file here is
just all the variables that I need
because
not that one that's what I want
so these are all the variables I need to
supply so I can kind of just copy and
paste these across to get this running
so my Docker registry
let me just grab the name of that again
so that's the first variable that I need
the next variable I need
um
so the next variable I'll have is the
service name
so we're calling this this sort of test
version video instead of video streaming
the next variable I need is the version
so that is going to be version 10 so
that's the version that we published
that we want to get on our kubernetes
cluster now I have to give it the
authentication details now I have to
give it the connection details it needs
to to connect to my kubernetes cluster
so I'm just going up to my cheat sheet
to just get some of these details
because they're quite big and uh
and you're not going to want to wait uh
watch me type these in
um so this is the kubernetes host that
we're connecting to
now uh comes the interesting bit it's I
need some of these certificates and and
connection keys and uh and these are the
big ones these are the ones that if I
cut and paste these directly to the
command line
somehow it corrupts them
um
I'm not really sure why
uh by the way all these details that I'm
typing in for connection with the
kubernetes cluster
um if you watch the first uh version of
this video you will see how I got these
you'll see how I built my cluster and
how that process of building it
um the output of that was all these keys
that I needed to connect to that cluster
now hopefully this is all good and I
have not typed anything wrong
just got one more there's CA certificate
I think that's all I need so now I can
run this batch or I need a line
continuation there don't need one there
yeah
do I need one there I've got one there
cool so that's all good let's just close
down this variable as well so you can
see this whole thing so this is the
command uh terraform ply Auto approving
it otherwise we'd have to type yes at
the command line
um and we're passing in a whole bunch of
variables to use within the terraform
code the things that it needs to be able
to connect to our infrastructure and
deploy stuff for us so I'm just gonna
run this
fingers crossed oh before I do that I'll
just show you uh the pods that we've got
running already
so these are the containers that are
already running on my kubernetes cluster
there is just this single video
streaming one but after I've deployed
the new one I should see one here that's
not video streaming it's just video it's
going to do the same thing I'm just
doing a demonstration to show you that I
can do this
I want the deploy script so I'm running
the bat the deploy batch file that I
just created
oh sorry deploy local
uh have I missed the line continuation
character here
that's really weird I don't know what's
wrong with that but I'm just going to
get rid of these line continuation
characters just put it on online
um
hopefully that will avoid me having to
figure out what's actually wrong with it
see
okay let's try that
run it again
fingers crossed prone to the demo gods
oh it's looking good it's creating
something
now hopefully this isn't going to take
too long
while that's going through actually
let's have a look at the terraform code
that makes this possible
so you've seen the variables file you
know that's where a bunch of variables
are set up you could put defaults in
here but you could say default uh equals
you know some some default of this
variable but the reason the fact that we
haven't got the defaults there is is why
you have to provide them why you have to
provide them at the command line
uh and so you're forced you're forced to
provide that configuration
the provider's terraform file is
basically just where we set up
kubernetes so this is where we're using
some of those variables so the the keys
here we're plugging these into our uh
okay connection details for our
kubernetes cluster
we've got uh this is the important one
so this is the
uh the terraform code that actually
deploys our
our microservice there's two parts to
this there's the kubernetes deployment
and the kubernetes service uh a
kubernetes deployment is something that
basically manages a replica set for us
and a bunch of PODS now we're only we're
only kind of instancing one pod here but
you could instance as many as you want
and this deployment is basically
responsible for keeping them alive if
any of them die it's gonna
boot them back up again so we start with
a bunch of metadata here
um here is the spec for the Pod is the
number of replicas so we only have one
of these things running we can easily
change it to three or Thirty however
many you want if you want like a load
balanced micro service that has many
workers really easy to kind of scale up
using terraform and kubernetes
and here we've got the template for the
container uh down here is where we're
plugging in the image so again here
we're using making use of variables
we're composing the image name of the
docker registry the service name and the
service version so that's using
terraform interpolation to basically
build that string and get that thing for
us and it kind of means we can we can if
we wanted to we could reuse this
terraform file for other other
microservices and we just plug in the
name we just plug in the name of the
thing that we're deploying so it's a
fairly common configuration
um there's an example of an
environmental variable configurator here
which tells the microservice which Port
it's going to use
and we can
configure other environment variables
here other environment variables that
that we might need to plug into our
microservice
now if you want to access this this you
know this first part this kubernetes
deployment that deploys our containers
uh into the kubernetes cluster if you
want to have them accessible via DNS you
have to put a kubernetes service on it
so that's what makes it exposed
internally
but what we're doing here is at the end
this this last bit is important because
adding a type load balancer is what
Provisions a load balancer an external
load balancer in the cloud vendor so
that we can get external access so if
this was going to be an internal micro
service only and you didn't want to
access this from the outside world you
just delete that and you have it like
that and it's just an internal private
microservice which can be good for
security most of your micro services in
your application are probably going to
be internal only and only because we
want to get to this from the outside
world so I can show you that it's
working do we put the load balancer on
there but you know if this was a if this
is your web server if it was your
gateway microservice something like that
you also want to do this you also want
to do this so you can expose it
okay let's have a look
cool that's gone through if I do Coop
control get pods now
we should see our video pod here
we can also do if you want to see the
actual deployment that's looking up at
that pod you can go uh Coupe control get
deployments
so that shows you there's a deployment
after that as well
uh
now let's let's look at the external IP
address for this if I do a get services
you can see uh we've got two external
IPS this one here is the external IP for
our latest one
so we can have a look at that it should
give us Hello computer great we should
have a video route great
we've just manually deployed a micro
service